eigentlich bin ich ein sehr fröhlicher
mensch doch dann passiert es manchmal
dass es regnet meine freunde sagen du
bist verrückt na klar es muss ja regnen
die blumen die bäume alles braucht sein
wasser aber ich komme nicht damit
zurecht
wenn ein marienkäfer auf seinen rücken
fällt man schafft es nicht mehr hoch
manche babys schildkröten schaffen es
nicht uns passen
drei mal drei macht doch nicht 4
wenn in china ein sack reis umfällt
wer hebt ihn dann wieder auf
logitech sind doch nichts anderes als
bunte tesafilm
was wäre denn katzen tauchen könnten
gebe es dann weniger fische
die prägen keine chance auch du wirst es
schaffen nach draußen zu gehen
bitte rufen sie jetzt ohne der
hotline-nummer nur 190 60 die sechs
herren und verlangen sie tieren spricht
partner zum thema reden depressionen wir
fast sich an ihnen eine
hundertprozentige erfolgsgarantie dass
auch sie wieder rausgehen können